businesses are facing issues they've
never faced before here's what i mean by
pre-pandemic to postpand they make it's
almost like even here to say when they
say you know it's like riding a bicycle
you never forget it well what's going on
today in work environment is like you
used to be single in 2005 where it
wasn't no tinder bumble any of that
stuff you've been married and you just
went through a divorce and you're back
in a dating scene and everything's
changed everything in the work
environment has dramatically changed in
two and a half years and many companies
are having a hard time making
adjustments to it today we're going to
talk about 10 post pandemic issues all
businesses are facing
[Music]
stake right for the variant for pdf and
a bonus point i'm going to give to you
uh in regards to today's content so
point number one on the biggest
challenge people are facing is getting
folks to go from being on zoom working
from home to working from the office now
many ceos many leaders many articles
these leaders were seen as innovative oh
my gosh in our company everybody can
work from home just go work from home
and all the employees were so happy oh
my gosh my office is so great my company
is so great don't let me work from home
so the co said this is kind of cool we
hold you accountable through zoom one
week two week four weeks eight weeks
twelve weeks that's kind of like where's
the culture this is not really working
out and they notice people working from
home were losing that connection to the
company in the organization and they
started simply applying for other jobs
there was no longer loyalty other people
were willing to pay more money to work
from home then the ceo flipped and said
no everybody's got to work from the
office now here's what we got to do then
the ceo automatically seen as a bad guy
wait a minute i said working from home
was okay now you're changing this you're
not predictable you're changing this
what's wrong with you it's a mistake of
a seo because he panicked she panicked
they didn't know how to handle it during
that time many leaders are going to do
that at times but now you have to
readjust that's one of the biggest
challenges leaders are having today and
unfortunately
during that adjustment you're going to
lose a lot of people and you're going to
have to hire new people and manage
expectations all up front letting
everybody know our company is work from
home now this doesn't apply to you don't
worry about point number one okay i got
point number two and three combined
together but it's under inflation so
here's what inflation has done in the
last 30 months two and a half years
right number one
inflation has gotten somebody just in
miami last year rent is up 30 percent in
one year some place is up 50 let me
explain to you what this means you were
paying 2 000 for rent now it's twenty
six hundred dollars imagine six hundred
dollars like that's not a lot of money
that's a four hundred dollar car payment
plus insurance and some places rent is
up fifty percent so you're paying two
thousand dollars now it's three thousand
dollars a month that thousand dollars
used to be your car payment car
insurance phone cable netflix now you
have to go make that money so
employees were sitting there saying look
i could make it off three grand a month
i could make it off four grand a month i
can make it up five grand a month or
somebody was making it off five now it's
eight seven nine but the increase has
taken place so cost with inflation has
increased cost of living for your
employees that leads to what
conversation that leads to a lot of
conversations of employees coming up to
you and saying what hey cost of living's
increased man i can't work off of you
know whatever you're paying me right now
i need a raise and then there is
friction between the employer and the
employee but the employer has to have a
certain set of understanding so does the
employee
in this situation if the employer is not
understanding of this taking place
because this is a real issue employers
ceos i'm one of them and i'm telling you
this is a real issue people are really
going through this you have to be aware
of it so either you're gonna have to
make an adjustment and say i have to cut
staff i can't pay for this stuff
or you have to realize the people that
are your superstars you got to figure
out a way to keep them now on the other
side employees if you're the person
that's watching this saying ooh this is
perfect video let me go ask my boss for
a raise
if you go in
wanting to take advantage of this and
kind of bully your employer that's also
unfair to them because they're going to
sit there and say dude i love you i want
you to be here but you're kind of using
this to your advantage and you're
cornering me and i don't appreciate it
because if i back then and i give it to
you right now what makes you think going
to be with me six 12 months from now i
just took a big risk because you may
take the new salary whatever the new
salary you're gonna get say you're gonna
go from
sixty thousand dollars to eighty
thousand dollars then you're gonna go to
a new company and say what do you make
at your current job i'll make 80 grand
if you pay me 95 i'll come up to you six
months later 4.95 so i just lost i gave
you 20. i backed down and i said no
problem i want to keep you and you left
me for another 15 grand so in the span
of three months you got a 35 000 raise
you know how i know that because i kind
of know that because that's happened to
me as an employer myself so
this issues create a friction my
suggestion to you employers if you want
to keep that employee have a real
conversation with them open just tell
them here's my challenges but i
understand your pain and employee have a
real open conversation with your
employer and tell them listen i love
this company i want to be here i don't
want to go anywhere else but i just want
to show you my expenses this was a year
and a half ago this is today this was my
rent a year and a half ago this is today
i'm not playing any games it's my life
it's more expensive if you're willing to
work with me and help me out i don't
want to go anywhere else you take that
approach the employer is going to say
you know what
thank you for taking that approach i'm
willing to work with you nine out of 10
times your employer is going to work
with you in these cases so point number
four is retention so i just explained
inflation and cost of living and keeping
employees because salary is going up and
what are you going to do with that cost
but retention is a complete different
thing going on because everybody's kind
of all over the place right oh my god
we're doing this all pre-zoom post zoom
working from home now working out of an
office what do i do now
immediately you need to call a meeting
if your department's 40 50 people call a
meeting if your business is 40 50 people
call a meeting if your leadership team
is 20 30 people call a meeting and have
a very transparent open conversation
with everybody hey
here's what we're doing here's what
we're standing for what's your biggest
concern here's the adjustment that we're
making we're going to come back and work
from home what do we want to do here
these are the things i'm not willing to
break and negotiate on i'm open to some
of these ideas what's important to you
and make that decision but prior to you
having that meeting
make sure you specifically know what
your non-negotiables are
and don't compromise your
non-negotiables but if you go in with 15
different things that i'm not going to
negotiate these 15 things
you're being a little bit unreasonable
there's got to be a give and take here
but don't compromise your
non-negotiables now the retention side i
have four categories of employees here's
my four categories of employees
my first category of employees are the
superstars rock stars that i want to
keep that i have to come to and give you
a raise make sense so you don't wait for
me to you don't come to me for a raise i
come to you for a raise i come to you
and say hey johnny you're doing a great
job here's what we're doing with you
boom you're part of the rock star you're
part of the superstar i want to keep you
then you got the second category of
employees whereas people that can do big
things they're doing big things and
maybe somebody else is going to make a
recommendation and maybe they're going
to come to you and they're going to say
hey here's what i'm going to be doing
maybe you want to figure out a way to
help them out and work with them but
that's the second category great
attitude love the company
they're pretty good at what they do not
level one that's high expertise high
loyalty high long term high true
believer you want to take care of this
guy these guys are true believers they
believe in the company they have a good
attitude maybe their expertise is not
there yet but you think long term they
can be somebody you want to take care of
them then you got the third ones that
are going to come in and they're going
to say you know that if you don't give
them a raise they'll stick around
if you do give them a raise they'll
stick around but if they come and ask
for a raise you'll also tell them i love
you can't do anything for you but i wish
you nothing but the best you have to
have that conversation then the fourth
level which is the one most
entrepreneurs and ceos make mistakes
with because they're afraid of this
they're afraid of the fourth level
because there's a fourth level that you
have to be
uh
assertive and you have to be proactive
and have to ask those guys to leave and
that's generally a smaller percentage of
your employees most people are
frightened of doing this they're okay
keeping a bad apple because all they're
worried about is our retention numbers
have to be flawless your retention
numbers is maybe a reason why you're
keeping a bad apple that's spreading
negativity and it's hurting 5-10 other
employees and it's time for you to have
the audacity to make that decision
very very hard to do almost every time
you do this you make an enemy
can't believe you're doing this i can't
believe you're doing that but that only
lasts 30 60 90 days sometimes 12 months
24 months but if you don't make this
decision you cannot take your company to
the next level so you as somebody who's
going free pre-covet during covet post
covet this is a very tough decision you
need to make but you need to take a time
out and say who's number one tier one
that i need to go to them who's tier two
that may be a recommendation who's tier
three we're not doing anything and who's
tier four we gotta kind of ask you to go
because company is going in a different
direction that's the decision you got to
make as a leader okay so this next one's
very weird it's political issues you
know three years ago we were working
not everything was politics during covet
basketball became about politics sports
became politics everything became
politics talking about china became
politics talking about covet became
politics taking a vaccine became
politics not taking a vaccine became
politics literally cartoons
everything in a lot if you think about
it everything's become politics the last
25 years so what happens there's a few
different ways leaders approach this one
they don't even talk about it like
imagine the elephant's sitting right
here and everyone's looking this way no
no the elephant's not in the room it's
not a new i don't want to look at him i
don't want to look at him you're not a
leader you're weak you got to get
stronger people want you to leave or you
simply have that conversation and you
manage expectations with everybody and
you say guys
lots changed the last two and a half
years is that fair to say yes i had an
event this last two days ago i'm in
orlando with 2 500 people in the room
and i got up and i said let me explain
to you guys what's going on everybody's
kind of wondering i said you know when 9
11 happened in 2001 and everybody's
trying to find their kids nobody said
hey
you're a republican i'm not gonna help
you because i'm a democrat or you're a
democrat i'm a republican i'm not gonna
help you no one cared where you were
politically no one cared if you're white
black hispanic everybody said you can't
find your kids i got your back because
i'm an american right i'm willing to go
help you find your kid i said during
covid
rather than china being the enemy in
america the opposing political party
became an enemy so everybody was walking
on eggshells everybody was extremely
sensitive we couldn't have a basic
conversation together so what if we
disagree on two percent of our lives but
we agree on 98 of things i had to have
that conversation with my guys to make
sure no one was walking on eggshells i
told them what questions do you have for
me i share with them my sentiment and my
philosophy
i hope you understand this is where i
come from but regardless it's the
company's vision let's go take over the
world right but if you don't have that
conversation i feel a lot of your guys
are following somebody that's afraid i
think today you have to kind of talk
about it to get all of it out in the
open not talk about it like this is what
i stand for i support pro-choice but i'm
not talking about that stuff that you
support i'm just saying saying here's
what's going on not everybody here
agrees together politically but do we
all have big dreams yes we all want to
make sure we do something that we can
talk about and be proud of yes why don't
we go make that happen as a company you
got to capitalize this moment to bring
people together and unify them under one
message with the vision of the company
or else there's going to be constant
conflict so next one is supply chain
shortages which everybody's going
through i bought two buildings okay the
building i'm in right now is the second
building i bought but the first building
i bought
i bought it thinking i was going to make
the vitamin headquarters there off a
federal and then my designer comes who
happens to be the ceo of this building
the owner of this building and he says
i said i want to set up windows i want
to create this set i want to do this i
want to do that i want to do this and
everybody's showing up and they said
well
glass is taking six to 12 months to get
such and such is taking 12 months to get
furniture's taking this much today this
is i'm like what are you talking about
says yeah that's how long it's taken so
i brought another designer and another
everybody said the same thing the
building i bought was gonna take six to
twelve months for it to be done to work
out of so immediately that same night
when i found this out i made an offer on
this building a week later
we agreed on terms and i eventually
ended up moving in here now this is our
building that we have off of dixie in
fort lauderdale but why because of
supply shortages so depending on the
industry you're in
some of you guys are watching what's
going on in china right now where the
covet cases all of a sudden are up and
they shut everything down people are
like oh my gosh it's unfair what they're
doing to china
of course it's unfair
what they're doing to the people in
china but if people are staying home
that means no chips are being produced
if chips are not being produced that
means automakers don't have chips to
create and build new cars if automakers
don't have chips to build new cars then
these prices of used cars are going to
go back up again if russia was the one
that was selling all to a lot of people
and they're not right now they're having
challenges that means gas price are
going to continue to go up so you have
to pay attention to supply supply chain
shortages based on the industry you're
part of and not be naive about it you
have to be very much
researching within your industry to know
everything that's going on with supply
chain because somehow some way no matter
what industry you're part of you're
gonna be hit either directly or
indirectly so point number seven this
one is a little bit uh weird because you
have to retrain everybody again what do
you mean by retrain
many people forgot to do the basic
things and i know this sounds kind of
weird scripts are basic think about it
this way i haven't done how-to videos
like this for four or five months right
even myself i used to do how-to videos
like this every tuesday right but i've
done it for five months i have to be
retrained again myself of course i do
when i got everything down but everybody
needs to be retrained i need to go back
and watch a few of my old how-to videos
to remember how i did how-to videos
because i need to be retrained you need
to be retrained employees need to be
retrained conflict resolution needs to
be retrained everything needs to be
retrained today in regards to your
company so retraining scripts retraining
communication retraining sensitivities
retraining people today on new
objections that may come up in regards
to covid
vaccine and you know pandemic that maybe
you did not have two and a half years
ago you need to train people on these
new issues what it is to come back what
it is to open up what it is to in every
possible way most of your employees are
not going to tell you this but they're
dying for you to retrain them they're
literally sitting there please retrain
me because i forgot how to do my
business
so this next one's going to cost you
some money but it's going to be the best
investment you're going to make in 2022
here's what it is so i had a meeting in
my house backyard we have a 10 97 people
are there and i'm talking to our guys
executives these are guys that are
running good-sized businesses and i said
what's the biggest challenge you're
having right now do you know what's
crazy 80 of what everybody said had to
do around conflict resolution so you
train all your guys on conflict
resolution let me explain to how this
thing works
politics conflict resolution vaccine not
anti you know pro-backs not maxed
conflict resolution working from home
working from office conflict resolution
give them a raise don't give a raise
conflict resolution sitting down to fire
somebody conflict resolution retraining
your old guys management because their
standards have dropped a little bit
conflict resolution having a tough
conversation to bring all your guys
together conflict resolution you will
see
80 of your problems you're facing right
now to come back and get your business
going again with the personalities
customers vendors companies partners
everybody is around one thing conflict
resolution conflict resolution there's
many books you can read on and many
courses you can take one of the best
ones is actually uh uh uh crucial
conversations they have this company out
of a salt lake city utah you hire a
trainer 10 or 15 000 they're going to
come to your office you take 10 or 20
employees in a room and they train all
your executives and directors on how to
resolve conflict together
in one room it may be one of the best
investments you make i'm not only doing
that with my home office executive team
that's coming up next week i'm not only
doing that with valuetainment home
office executive team i'm also doing
that with my sales leaders team to come
together for them to know how to resolve
conflicts together because most people
the last two and a half years actually
got worse at conflict resolution and the
approach and the philosophy they use is
what avoidance of conflict catastrophic
for any organization okay so that's
eight points you got but there's two
additional points that you can only get
on valuetainment.com and the whole pdf
with the two additional points if you
want to get that click over here go
subscribe to the newsletter you watch
those last two points but if you don't
want to do that there's another video i
want you to watch here on youtube titled
how the pandemic exposed leaders if you
want to see that click here take care
everybody bye
[Music]